is it true something'll objects and you  takes on two things now you're not keen  on here to bear witness to the fact that  Sam likes to move fast  no I don't I don't I don't vary that  much I'm not that actor at the same  thing alter but sometimes and I could  speak from experience like Sam is so  charismatic and he has been for as many  years you've been making movies and  sometimes CMAs Sam and you just kind of  go out of the scene and you're just  watching Sam being sad and it's really  powerful you go hang on a second What's  My Line I've only had that well I was  doing a movie with Dustin Hoffman and in  middle of shot Dustin just stops it cut  cut Sam I saw you see you saw me what  said I saw you say to yourself oh my god  that's Dustin ha  you were amazed you are made oh my god  I'm acting with  we must ask you James Bond Tom  Hiddleston what's the scoop what's going  on um a demonstration of my hidden  talent at Poldark all deaths